how's Gomes Manny's pierpan are you
feeling how are you feeling a little
frisky I can tell any you look you look
freaky as [ __ ]
I was talking to nail not you hi how are
you hi now how is your exam thanks for
studying with me I passed the exams
because of that I like to treat you for
lunch in exchange for your help
let's go to Retta Nando's why would we
go to Nando's this doesn't look like
Nando's at all but I like the music it's
so emotional I used to eat shaitaan'
would you like to play what happened to
his [ __ ] face what is that ready
studies oh okay we're eating um
this is what you do with dates press if
you ever go on a date with one direction
just [ __ ] eat your heart out dirt
you're not gonna break [ __ ] but I used to
good I'm clicking so much it bleeds from
my nips Wow
maybe even a lot you've eaten more my
[ __ ] sorry yeah I'm so full now we
should probably get going yeah it's been
a long day we should do this again next
time bye
take care I was the best damn date of my
life fighting I better call him right
away
he thought World of Warcraft and all
those mmo's were hardcore while you
ain't playing this [ __ ] now let's let's
flirt with other boys I play this
[ __ ] game for 37 days where did my
life go oh my god
we're best friends you can out did you
yes oh [ __ ] you Liam what Taylor Taylor
Swift hey yeah are you back yes what do
you need
sorry how here you stay away from Mary
whoa whoa whoa whoa it's on Taylor Swift
battle challenge oh god she's ugly punch
that [ __ ] pepper spray aah punch a
[ __ ] Oh Scott she touches there's some
real catfight going on in all this [ __ ]
Oh got any health potion [ __ ] you
[ __ ] problem no Taylor what's going
on here
Harry she hurt me Christ what what
happened I was just started her and she
started yelling at me No
then she hit me and told me to go away
hmm it's his trap no Harry don't believe
her she started this how dare you even
lie I want to be friends with you but
you told me that I will steal her from
you enough just leave us alone
Taylor whoa he sees through her lies
fine suit yourself what the [ __ ] I don't
know exactly what happened but I know
that you won't do anything like that
why because I trust you
and
I love you oh my god arias in love with
me I'm so happy I met you you changed my
life
you showed me that life goes and stuff
you made me realize that my ex was two
stepping-stone to something better
someone better
and that person is y'all you're the love
I love I love you love yes
that was [ __ ] beautiful I never
thought I'd kiss Harry Styles I never
thought I'd like it so much either
can we visit Harry's house now what
after all that he won't let me in his
house day 38 that was a serious day of
fangirling what happens if we talk to
him now when it's my birthday uh it's
kind of its kind of sad who I remember
that damn look at that whoa look at that
exp look at that exp how many drinks do
you need Harry this song what does that
mean I want to introduce you to someone
this is my good pal Justin hey hey
Justin I have to go out for a minute
I'll leave you guys for now hey what's
up now told me a lot about you I think
he likes you so much I love you more
Justin
really really
well do you want to go out I'm bored
with this place girl you don't want to
go out because you're bored Justin don't
[ __ ] lie now we'll be upset if he
finds out why I'm a cold-hearted [ __ ] I
don't want to ran your friendship just
because of a girl oh I'm sorry
now where are you now now it's missing
you better find out what happened now
she doesn't seem to be here such as
house for clues
this giant book today I'm going to meet
my friend mint yeah I'll introduce our
troop my buddy Justin bad moob your two
are my close friends I really like a bet
here she makes me happy all the time I
just wish I could tell my feelings what
a [ __ ]
now I'll help Mean Girls I know that
we're up to something
thinks it's going so fast for us I can't
even process what are you doing here I
heard now screaming stay away from her
Domingos run away as the police are
coming oh okay miss yeah are you all
right how you got kidnapped what the
[ __ ] I am
Emma I thank you for coming into my life
you don't know how happy I am to have
met you
well that's too bad I don't like your
back [ __ ] this game is so hard I spied
it I don't even want to know how many
hours I spent in this game bros the
things I do pretty I pour myself I
actually love this game alright I'm
earning a lot of money so I can take him
out on a nice [ __ ] date cuz I'm just
pimped like that alright where should we
take him the wedding chapel
all right let's make this [ __ ] horny uh
what do you like most in a guy um his
intellect
what the [ __ ] do you want from me Harry
can we do something else are you [ __ ]
kidding me it's so hard what do you want
from me Harry you [ __ ] [ __ ] don't
think I see through your [ __ ] hair
what would fit me most fabulous amazing
extraordinary oh my god brilliant
for now the fangirls are just too clever
man yes okay I got it
oh come on I didn't get enough what a
[ __ ] [ __ ] you are not mad so hard 59
days what kind of movies does he like ah
yeah yeah well [ __ ] you too
good thing I saved all right I need a
[ __ ] Harry and that's fast what the
[ __ ] do you want from me you're too
demanding Harry I can't god I could have
[ __ ] done it by now
[ __ ] you too Harry I'd swear to god I
tried every [ __ ] caller with this
[ __ ]
getting so pissed off uh Capricorn no
[ __ ] you then you [ __ ] [ __ ] ass
licking mother [ __ ] [ __ ]
what else do you want from me what kind
of [ __ ] demands you have of a woman
you're sick [ __ ] bastard
it's very Harry [ __ ] Styles what eles
you run from me really are you [ __ ]
kidding me you're such a [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] I answer all your [ __ ]
questions right what else do you want
from me
see how are we I'm done please like I've
enjoyed his [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
[ __ ] cuz I went through hell thank you
stay awesome brother